it is Saturday night in Hollywood that
means it's time to battle the [ __ ] out
I'm Kevin Smith
and I'm Ralph Garman I want to thank
Kevin Smith for sitting in for our usual
co-host tonight it's good to be back
feels excellent to be back man go home
it's nice to be here I missed it I
missed it a lot I love coming down those
steps I'm ready to go stuff to show my
baby I'm ready I'm about a quart low
I'll be right with you all right
Megan grab my pina colada is that what
you're calling it these days yeah I was
on vacation I had a piña colada I was
like this is [ __ ] amazes the best
booze that ever happened so now I'm
looking for it ever I went to Burger
King knows like you got pina colada they
didn't come and do the dark side young
Skywalker first thing let's get some
business out of the way we are taking
the show on the road I don't think we
talked about it together yes people have
been asking are we gonna go out there
and meet some people outside of the
halls of the Jon Lovitz pop podcast
theatre and we are we're going to San
Diego first we're gonna be down there
the weekend of the San Diego Comic Cons
some of you may have heard of it going
where the House of Blues I believe that
it is it's HBO at the Hib get out of
here that's awesome HBO table man get
hobble the [ __ ] mr. man dirty bird
hobbled the [ __ ] on I'm gonna [ __ ]
and then Vegas in August yes we are
going out and playing the show in Vegas
and also
thank you there's your people also there
my penis Kalani's colada then also I
don't have the dates or not confirmed we
haven't announced yet but we're going on
a mini Texas tour right well so there's
about I think three or four stops that
we're gonna be doing in Texas and I
believe that's in August at some point
so look for us in a town near you yeah
I'm coming your way although the people
in this room were like so who cares
that's later yeah what about tonight
[ __ ] stop selling and one more thing
to sell this is brand new that just
literally came off the presses so I want
to give you your chance if you're
interested the the very first official
Hollywood babble-on
t-shirt those are available tonight over
there where the Garmon shirts are
usually pretty rough and eyes the
cartoon character you sometimes see on
the on the page is adorable and there's
a whole bunch so there'll be a bunch of
t-shirts correct
yeah well had like limited editions yes
there's one it basically you see hold it
up again there's me and him sitting next
to each other then the shirt changes by
putting us into two separate characters
so the next one or one of the next ones
is Ralph is dr. Peter Venkman and I'm
Slimer yeah this dude's a genius who's
the GU this is Michael wait he's a guy
in England who just he's a graphic
artist and he sends us his stuff says
all I just came up with this one he
sends us one of us is Batman and Robin
or Taylor the astronaut and Cornelius
the chimpanzee from Planet of the Apes
you may have seen the cartoon eat it
with us as Indiana Jones and Saleh from
Raiders so he's our official graphics
guy and was awesome he's a genius like
that broader wrote the Potter books yeah
because he's from England same thing but
she's out of work now that's true yeah
she's biting for money yeah really yeah
you can probably get her okay
all right let's start the show as we do
every week with some shout outs saying a
Lotus of people who came especially long
distances or here for special occasions
wanted to give them a little heads up
and thanks for coming out Christina and
Nate are you guys in the audience
tonight just you know Nate hi guys
that was so phonetic she's like we are
here very well no contractions in that
family my husband made has been enjoying
your podcast since the beginning and
despite my better judgment and superior
taste that's how it's gonna be is it
he got me hooked on HBO as well a few
months back I got him tickets to your
show on the 25th as a Father's Day
present which I knew would go over well
because he is a cheap ass even though
your tickets tickets to your show don't
exactly break the bank he would really
make our night if you could tell him
what an amazing husband and father he is
aside from him being a cheap ass as Edie
Wynn my personal favorite impression
thanks so much for being more amusing
than I initially thought possible she
writes I don't think I like this broad
at all it sounds like one of those
compliments where I'm like how was that
and she was like your dick was adequate
yeah
you weren't the worst [ __ ] I've ever had
you came oh my goodness Nate why are you
so cheap life's for the living for god
sakes open up your wallet your tight ass
by these people around the drinks at
your table these strangers buy them
something show us all but you're not a
cheap [ __ ] Nate even your wife hates you
also here tonight that's a good [ __ ]
mantra man a good man sure to live by
like living I'm gonna remember that
every time I'm feeling down and [ __ ]
like that like the thing walking on your
shoulder it boom life is for the living
Cadbury laughs I'm a local hold on one
sec okay I'm just disappointed my wife
sexually again I'm sitting in my [ __ ]
office why am I such a loser
Kevin life is for the living don't worry
about it don't you know thanks Ralph as
Edwin you know and then I go about my
bag I like it how about Cynthia Sal and
John are you guys you Wow
you're right up front sir we don't need
to yell that never happens very aware
that you there
I could tell cuz you're right in front
of me waving and I knew you were here
alright he's the Bai Ling fan club
president two weeks ago I was well drunk
two weeks ago madam you're lucky I
remember that I'm here tonight said he
was I he's the violin playing [ __ ] it was
like yeah yeah we don't say violin here
that's right
small viola
Cynthia rides my two friends and I will
be attending the June 25th show this
will be my and Sal's third time at the
show and John's second time and we have
yet to see Kevin host the podcast
[Music]
Wow I don't want to start referring to
him as Kevin the one who misses the
podcast when I go Smith but I'm starting
to get a complex actually I apologize
Kevin I know you did ask me to warn you
when Cynthia was coming to the show so
you could cancel but I completely forgot
that chick come on he's like yeah forgot
hey I'm here man hey how are you I'll
try to turn it on just for you guys let
the rest these people just buckle they
know what they're in for
how about Martin and Sandra from
Stockholm Sweden are you guys here where
are you guys up at the top there Wow are
you are you more comfortable on top of a
mountain or something but Sweden is that
way you chose the third floor well tap
it happy to have you here
no man are from Sweden so they want to
be up top where they can [ __ ] private
I say cuz they're sexy during the show
to us they'll bear Fahmy shirt Paul
right there sorry put much thought into
it
my fianc and I come from Stockholm
Sweden to LA for vacation and hit the
jackpot scoring some HBO tickets yeah
these are impossible to get harder debt
than the Grammys I don't know how you
worked your way and you got third floor
seats to possibly scored those CityWalk
like who's trying to sucker tourists
these are really hard to get these are
Hollywood babble-on tickets I'll sell
you this and the big H in the Hollywood
sign
see in our language jackpot means good
yeah in in Sweden it's [ __ ] we couldn't
get into any other real comedy act
it's fondue pot that is nice really the
good things like oh we hit the fondue
pot so it's all farfegnugen here that's
all I know
please give us a shout out in the voice
of the special needs McDonald's girl oh
you Swedes are cruel well they have
euthanasia there in that country so
they're capable of anything I kind of
retired that voice cuz it upset a lot of
people it does upset a lot of people yes
and there are people with special needs
and the parents of people with special
needs and I got lots of angry emails so
I I Know What You kids autistic do it
just gave us a license from an autistic
mom that's like you know every time a
autistic mom gives you a pass an angel
gets its wings with you like fries we
can give you an amplified to native
apple pies in Austria where you're from
we also have Big Macs wherein they say
in your country burn it all right there
you go
[Applause]
[Music]
- just when they thought you weren't
ever coming to hell they get to warm the
bed up for you yet they're screwing the
plaque on the door of my office
hey everybody he's coming back Martin
adds my fiance is riding the cotton pony
this week
so this shout-out might get me a bj back
at the hotel you are sexy bastard you
sweet for another time pound ralph and
kevin writes Tara is Tara here Tara hi
Tara how are you Tara writes attending
your Hollywood babble-on show on the
25th traveling from Redding California
way up north by Oregon since I'm in town
alone I'll be the loner at the table for
one [ __ ] out of here
are you really by yourself are you here
for another reason you came to see us
what other things work or something
going to a class you're something you're
never alone at a Hollywood babble-on
people to the right into the left review
will be glad if you gave them anal
that's usually how it works out
let's warrant you won't come up here and
sit with us she's by herself dinner well
it's nice that she came I've gone to
many movies have been like one please
I know how rough it is I've always
waited for somebody to be like sit next
to me never happens I've really waited
for them be like sitting next to me
comes now
this is Kara everybody everybody say hi
Kara see you're not alone anymore Tara
yeah do you want to asipi how do you
feel a little hello and this gentleman
brought you up your food and your drink
we can have food up here this changes
the show completely for me oh we're
screwed now yeah love it usually has a
whole dinner up here while we record let
me continue reading your email Tara is a
Tara or Tara how do you prefer it Tara
okay so hold on say it doesn't happen
unless you do about mics they had
everybody high since I'm coming to the
show alone well how many times you're
gonna bring that up in the [ __ ] email
we get it you're alone how about
throwing a shout out for me to my roller
derby team the Shasta roller derby
you're a Roly to roller derby you're a
derby dollar well our team is fully
nonprofit and we do lots of community
fundraising a shout out from Kevin would
be a wonderful gift to my girls for our
hard work and ass-kicking on the track
Kevin you want to give a shout out to
the Shasta roller derby I don't think so
okay she adds our roller skates allowed
at the show no teryn I hope you didn't
wear them because it's a strict no
skates policy here
she also says a picture with Kevin would
absolutely make my trip and surely
remain my profile pic on Facebook for a
year well you got this Nick next to them
that's better than a picture do you have
a camera give it to somebody they'll
take our picture he'll he'll take it
very loudly put your violin down you're
right
take a pic I don't think you need a
flash we got the lights on up here
[Music]
now that work out work out oh that's a
good one
that is a facebook picture
all right literal extra man yeah I lost
my lost my sense of depth perception all
right that's how about Alan and Richard
from Glasgow Scotland Roger
Glasgow lot the show never failed to
listen we appreciate it guys we're in
the US for two weeks are you guys all
right over there yeah it's cute those
are really great in here we're at the
prom we really know what that means
after the prom yeah brain'll baby can do
runner skates just don't get behind her
he'll be chasing her all the way around
your ankles look out penguin I don't
think she wanted to [ __ ] me I did I was
just some skates out and Richard Wright
we're in the US for two weeks and we
just had to get our fill of [ __ ] jokes
and whatnot well you came to the right
place fellas our friend Scott couldn't
be here tonight he needs to be told
where his priorities line that he should
have come with us on our next trip he
would make us feel right at home if you
would pick on him in the voice of Sir
Sean Connery of course well I'm sure
Sean ever did meet him he would call him
a [ __ ] say says Alan and Richard credits
then their email with well Scott you
didn't come through oh thank you very
much I appreciate that
Scott you didn't come on the trip the
United States with your friends Alan and
Richard I would say that makes you a
[ __ ]
but it turns out you're not mad enough
to be a Content your pushy galore is
what you are
all right there we go Heather writes I'm
bringing my boyfriend Rogelio to the
show this Saturday Heather no Haley over
here says right here's that did you get
the pronunciation right is that right
you know why cuz I remembered now as I
read this he worked as an intern at K
Rock FM this past semester that's how I
know the guy cuz he was an intern on our
show he also knows Kevin Kevin he gave
you a cookie one time in the mall well
that narrows it down remember that guy
who gave you that cookie that time you
know what I remember every guy that ever
gave me a cookie I don't which mall
Sherman I do remember that you weren't a
little boy or anything were you at the
time hey you want a cookie I think we
were in a bathroom the back of a panel
van in the parking lot he lured you in
with his snickerdoodle be awesome to
give a shout out for his birthday that
would be awesome well happy birthday
rohypnol as I used to call you back to
the station this comes from Nick my
brother Andy and I will be coming to the
show on the 25th you guys hear
everybody's not very exciting Steve Nick
if everything goes to plan we'll be
dragging along our sister-in-law Johnny
who has flown all the way down from Fort
Wainwright Alaska wow we're hoping you
could give me a birthday shout-out as
Peter Lorre since he and I share the
same birthday as does Harley Quinn Smith
same birthday as Peter Lorre did you
know that would be tomorrow really happy
birthday to unique I hope no one poisons
your stabs you lurk strangles your
shoots you got to cut your guts out and
wears them around their neck is a bow
tie he was a creepy dude that's I be
honor if you do a shot with me in
celebration in accordance with the
babylon shot drinking policy section 8
675 309
wait a minute 8 6 75 3 own I I mean I
know that number yeah I will I'll do a
shot with you for your birthday
absolutely sir oh you're not bringing me
one are you what is it
patron I can't drink the Keele it makes
me vomit I'm sorry you thought you meant
a shot in the mouth no I can't I can't
drink tequila but the heels the one that
makes me sick
really yeah yeah what's your [ __ ]
cryptid you shoulda told me I shadow
Jack or something he will do it a little
bit later right but thank you thanks for
wearing the garbage shirt should I keep
it [ __ ] [ __ ] in his mouth like [ __ ]
your shot sit down I just I don't I
don't want to reject the shot that's bad
form right so he's trying to warn him do
it it did reject hold it and just put it
down and not drink with them that would
be what they do in the movies with like
ok 1 2 3
how about this one my fiance JD is JD in
the audience tonight JD where's JD JD is
here your parties as part of your
bachelor party
ah that's [ __ ] sad it's like two guys
and they're here is how many three three
really don't have a lot of friends huh
JD you know you don't need a lot of
friends you just need two who are
willing to jerk you off tonight or one
well at JD this email comes from your
fiance Caitlin Caitlin right
moaning already my fiance JD and I have
been together for six years she rates
six and a half years I'm sorry we're
getting married in two weeks he's going
to be the show tonight as part of his
bachelor party Ralph can you please tell
him don't do anything stupid in your al
pacino voice thanks Caitlin what the
[ __ ] is she thinking
he's got nothing to worry about they
came here JD come on now you're gonna
let this woman tell you what to do JD I
don't know about you but some woman says
don't do anything stupid I'm [ __ ]
somebody two weeks they put on the
chains tonight you're free come on now
anal with a hooker no condom male hooker
you take it life is for the living
[Applause]
hey man this chick came here alone not a
hooker no you fight on charge yeah I'm
Sam why Paige you're behind crime maybe
give it away
yeah all right step bet you think got
skates now that would be a bachelor
party meeting the two guys we all [ __ ]
the same girl she was on roller skates a
story
are you a jammer locker not a jammer
yeah blockers could take it I don't know
anything about the sport of roller derby
what is the difference in a jammer and a
blocker all right well you're in for a
good time tonight Jaden the jammers are
the ones that chase the Golden Snitch I
see they're the ones on the broom yeah
okay you know I realize we don't have a
jingle for the shoutouts we should get
one we've got a jingle for almost every
segment on the show if you're listening
and you want to be involved in the show
in some way shape or form create a
really funny jingle we'll use it we
don't like to pay for anything no and we
like jingles for everything cuz it makes
us were able to masquerade like this is
a real show that way like for instance
we have a jingle for the emails
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reaction first one
comes from Lance Corporal Ryan he's in
the Marine Corps and he's in Camp
Pendleton after spending four years in
the Corps I've been stationed at Camp
Pendleton I found that nothing in
California brings me more joy than
Hollywood babble-on how nice is that
what are you laughing at the next load
though I go I never got to see the show
live Uncle Sam's a douche you're right
I've listened to every podcast from day
one thanks for making the last year of
my military service bearable stay golden
Lance Corporal Ryan USMC and garmi by
the way well thank you corporal
lance corporal for defending our shores
because as far as I know Camp Pendleton
has never been invaded he's doing a hell
of a job down there yes Eugene writes
from Melbourne Australia
sorry Melbourne as they say down there
Australia I'd had to share this picture
I happened upon to scene from clerks
rendered in Legos have you seen this
I've seen the clerks and Legos before
but maybe not this one he sent this
along this apparently is from a place
called brick world which has displays in
Chicago and Indianapolis enjoyed the
podcast loved Eugene he sent us a
picture along there it is there that's a
yeah it's clerks and Legos it's Dante
hanging a sign there and if you look to
your right you can see our boy Kevin
there standing in front with news listen
to the boom box right there I wish shows
that then the J is good he's got a
lady's wig on next emails from Dave he
writes as you may have heard New York
State just passed a pretty important
bill
[Applause]
I know is kind of obscure he writes
jokingly I'm sure maybe you West
Coasters haven't heard the news yet but
New York just legalized marriage
equality I was out drinking with my
friend Mallory at the time and she was
so overwhelmed with joy that she broke
down in tears
nothing better than a crying lesbian in
my opinion that is hot know what that
means I was like if you guys would give
her a shout-out and maybe sing Lady
Gaga's Born This Way in the Edwyn voice
I want to work tonight okay really
quickly I dutifully in my way cause God
makes no mistakes I'm on the right track
baby I was born this way and life is for
the living Kevin so we I wouldn't have
even known how to sing the song you know
that song yeah you just sing express
yourself by Madonna plug in new words
and it's very simple mikheil from
where's he from the Netherlands writes
love your show found this interesting ad
for home solar panels have no idea where
it's from but the artist was truly
inspired here's a photo from a brochure
for home solar power I can't explain
that I somebody sent that to me on the
internet and I felt like Homer with mr.
sparkles
I was just by what is this and Silent
Bob saying my solar panels will save on
my gas bills J's saying yeah but they're
expensive and what I can't read upside
down but yeah it's not worth it he's
laughing about [ __ ] smoking I don't sure
but I don't know why Booker's Jay and
Silent Bob are selling solar panels
somebody somebody who's doing the
clipart and they're like why not look
like these guys it's your lawyer on the
phone yeah I might get me out of there
the code is shorter that's the only
difference between me and the drawing is
the code Layton real life goes way down
and here it comes up - it's like a HIPAA
code or someone well he's so warm
because he has solar panels he doesn't
need the full length code oh there we go
sir
Nick ego cheers Tim your name sir Nick
happy birthday sir that's about there
for the shot I'm sorry about the other
thing but I'm sure the other shot of
HeLa won't go to waste
yeah it's yours that's what I thought
what Bergland burgling is it really
spell it Bri er GL I am GTL I am
Bergland burgling your middle names not
turd is it Nick turd burglar would be a
bad name all you have to do in life is
not that but how do you not do it when
it's your name's I would so be a burglar
my name was Bergland what are you doing
/ kalain ya didn't have much of a choice
what do you do for a living Nick what do
you think hey what are you in for why
should they never have to ask you when
he's in prison this comes from Eileen in
Norway jeez it's cool people write from
all over the world listener from Norway
here wouldn't let you know that because
of stupid American drinking laws you two
better keep HBO alive until February
2014 so I can come to the United States
and drink with you because let's be
honest what's HBO without alcohol
a lot less funny when I get my ass over
there I demand a shout out for traveling
over 8,000 miles that's from Eileen in
Norway you think we can do this 2014
three more years we haven't even
celebrated our one-year anniversary I
think it's August right it's coming up I
mean we haven't we've been broadcasting
pretty consistently but we have yeah
well some of us have I don't think we're
gonna make it to our first birthday I
think we got about 10 weeks man we got
to figure out what it is and make sure
we do a birthday celebration I think we
may be in Vegas you know what we should
do actually this is [ __ ] weird but
it's very spur-of-the-moment you know
we're moving everything up here now that
this show was born and a little little
space not too far from here called smart
castle right and SModcast so we're
closing down and reopening up here on
the top floor because this is where we
spend all of our time now so smart
castle closes I think July 1st so I was
thinking about maybe doing a one last
show there to close out the space
there's only 50 seats yeah it'd be
pretty you know that we'll put up
tickets for sale this week like $200 a
piece though right yeah we don't lose
money on there you know but it feels
like we should honor the space where the
show was born before it goes goodbye
forever
no look for it look for that this week
if you want to come up and see that I
used to bring my own liquor to that
theater yeah it was really it was that
space birth this show and this show
brought us up here and we enjoyed doing
this every [ __ ] week while I was gone
I missed it so much but it feels like
let's honor the space before it goes
away all right let's do it
probably Wednesday I'm thinking
Wednesday I mean this email comes from
Seth his name is I'm sure he missed the
Jay on the keyboard whose name is Seth I
don't know but I'm thinking he writes
while you were gone Kevin while you were
here when we did the Back to the Future
penis point with that creepy kid yeah
me right we showed that video why are we
gone we also did the Star Wars boob grab
where Han grabs Princess Leia's boob in
Jedi as the universal that one where the
it's whether defending the shield
generator thank you so much she gets hit
and she fakes like being injured and she
goes I love you yeah before that when he
grabs her he's hopeful and grabs her tit
while he's lowering her to the ground
yeah yeah loser by the boob but with
using the force so we showed that clip
so now apparently it's a very popular
feature cuz everyone is sending in other
clips that we need to talk about so
maybe we'll make this a segment to call
the Easter egg hunt or something but
this comes from Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban during the final
credits apparently they show the
marauders map and you know the Marauders
matches the footprints where everyone is
in buddy isn't Hogwarts right in the
lower left hand corner on your screen as
we watch this they show two sets of
footprints that are totally at the
missionary position and going at and
having sex during the closing credits of
Harry Potter so I brought in the video
for everyone to look at we show it a
couple times it will zoom in but they're
totally [ __ ] on the map someone snuck
it in and figured no one would notice
but we did notice and here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rerun it lower left-hand corner right
there there they go they're going at it
one more time and close up here we go
now it's time to fix a tit I think it's
Harry and Ron though that's the only
problem oh you know they call it a
Hollywood babble-on [ __ ] that should not
be this comes from Scotland apparently
Kevin they are making a movie about us
in Scotland they're making a small
independent feature based on Hollywood
babble-on this comes from listener
Thomas towner actually he's from London
saw this and thought of you guys it's an
advertisement for actors sure for a
short film made in Scotland about you
guys in Babylon perhaps you could
audition and see how far you get this is
a screen grab of the ad they put on the
Internet at something called star now
and it says Kevin Smith look-alike
wanted for online short in Edinburgh
Scotland and it says the show will
follow Kevin and Ralph as they attempt
to deal with the abomination they have
created and entity simply known as The
Fame [ __ ] applicants must be heavily
built bearded and be able to do a New
York New Jersey accent in order to play
the fictional version of Kevin Smith
then in smaller print it says Ralph
Garman also required know here's the
second shot of the the exact
specifications for the actors to play
Kevin Smith you must be a male aged 18
to 99
thought I was looking better no previous
acting experience required to play Kevin
Smith fair enough the description for
Ralph Garman Ralph is a whiskey drinking
leather coat wearing wiseass first of
all I only wear the leather coat when
it's cold out I'm not like Fonzie I
don't go I don't I don't go waterskiing
in it I don't I don't go on the beach
with it you are like Fonzie
the more I think about it your leather
jacket cool your hair looks like Fonzie
every time I see you the first thing you
say is hey sit on it Kevin no previous
acting experience to play me either so
if you're in Edinburgh you might want to
apply and see if you can be in the new
movie about me and Kevin which I think
we also have to get our lawyers on
because that seems it would be a very
expensive joke for us to show up and be
like we'd like to try out I would like
to try out for Ralph Garman like I'll be
playing the role of Kevin Smith yeah
yeah and lastly the more video clips
from Disneyland Disney days we played
one a couple weeks ago I guess it was
with Chewbacca dancing to sweet child of
mine I think it was from Guns & Roses
and you were stoned enough to think you
might have been hallucinating it yes
yeah well Jason apparently liked that so
much he said it's another clip
apparently at Disneyland they had these
Disney days and one of the events that
they do is they have the cast members
come out in full regalia and they dance
too weirdly inappropriate songs so last
time we brought you Chewbacca dancing to
sweet child of mine tonight we bring you
Darth Vader embarrassing himself too
can't touch this James
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's not quite so scary when he's doing
those moves that [ __ ] rocks that was
amazing I can't even make fun of it that
is so [ __ ] well how come nobody's
ever done that before this is a
no-brainer take a hammer song put Vader
in it major time all right now this is a
bad week for this segment Tinseltown
Steph's a lot of good people past this
week but we have to give them their just
desserts this is not the funniest part
of the show but we do like to give them
a little bit of a tribute as we say
goodbye to some people that we're all
fans of with a segment we call
Tinseltown steps and now another edition
of
they will be missed they will be missed
are you eating her food
I just took off right I mean technically
it's not eating her food it's just uh
pride okay
sad news this week Ryan Dunn of Jackass
Fame passed away this week yeah it was a
horrible story just bad on every level
he had just turned 34 years old he was
with his 30 year old friend Zachary
Hartwell was in the car with him they
unfortunately he was drinking and
driving his blood alcohol content was
almost double two and a half times the
legal limit
they say he was driving about 130 miles
per hour in his Porsche when he went
through the guardrails of a highway and
burst into flames hit a tree just the
horrible horrible accident and of course
he was great in jackass they're very
entertaining and it's a shame that he
had to pass in such a horrible way but
at least the Westboro Baptist Church
made things better they announced this
week that any public funeral ceremony
for done will be picketed by the church
they mentioned that he is a drag pervert
who hocked porn level filth to get rich
from a perverse generation to which I
would ask well then description alright
the WBC said he was a drab pervert who
hocked porn level Phil to get rich from
a perverse generation do what I say
that's wrong I don't want to be right
I'm right there with him so he will be
missed big bucket of win there for Ryan
also this week Larry Wildman Fischer
passed away you may not all know the
name but he was a legend in what they
called outsider music this guy was
actually mentally ill he was living on
the streets of the Sunset Strip in the
60s and Frank Zappa found this guy and
decided to make him a rock star now if
you ever listen to a show called the dr.
Demento show back in the day there used
to be a single on that the dr. Demento
playing all the time called my name is
Larry do you remember that song that was
Larry the wild man
but Zappa made a to album set an album
with this guy back in the 60s and it
actually made him a celebrity he was
mentally ill he would make up his his
songs on the spot the the hit for lack
of a better description for the song
that was he was best known for was the
thing called merry-go-round so if you
don't know Larry Fisher's work here's a
little taste of merry-go-round still
better than Willow Smith in my opinion
no better than whip my hair back and
forth his cult status led him to open
for Solomon Burke The Byrds and Alice
Cooper in concert he used to open for
the magic gonna now his group are shown
seeing that guy sing for 40 minutes yeah
apparently these fall he had a falling
out with Zappa after he went crazy and
threw a jar at Frank Zappa and almost
hit his babymoon unit at the time and
then Wright decided to part ways with
the crazy wild man Fisher but he passed
away this week as well
comic book fans know this name Gene
Colan passed away this week he was a
legend in the business he was a great
great artist did Dracula drew Batman in
the 80's daredevil Ferg Lisa's run on
Daredevils one the definitive daredevil
runs of all time
Howard the Duck he was the artist for
Howard the Duck his work on tomb of
Dracula was famous for Marvel Comics as
well he also he was he was my favorite
hired man artist here's a cut a cover he
drew this was Iron Man number one that
he did the work for he passed away at
the age of 84 years old this week so
that's a big bucket away big bucket a
win man beautiful work to find those
characters a lot of what we know about
them and see today is based on that
dudes work I have a piece a Karen page a
page of Karen page that
in our daredevil run we killed off the
character of Karen page and Jimmy and
Joe the guys that did the run with they
gave me a gene : page and it was
originally yeah that's cool nice more
comic book art news an artist named Lou
Sara Schwartz he was a Batman artist
died at the age of 84 he was one of the
ghost artists for Bob Kane who created
the Batman of course when he was
originally drawing the strip the
workload got too big for Bob Kane said
they would farm it out to other guys but
Bob would still sign his name - it isn't
that nice loose hair Schwartz was one of
those guys did a ton of work from 48 to
53 this is one of his covers one of the
all-time greats that's the Red Hood
they're killing Joker under yeah so 84
years old also big bucket a win for him
gonna win of the week this one hurt
Peter Falk TVs Columbo died this week
the age of 83 years old first late
Columbo 1968 a TV movie then it became a
regular TV series from 71 to 1976 and
then sporadically after that from 89 to
2003 just a great great actor this dude
is a huge bucket of one is the Obie win
Kenobi this guy just unbelievable IVs
and the work you produce the end laws if
you've never seen the in-laws this is a
brilliant performance by by this man
also Alan Arkin Zinn the movie is also
[ __ ] brilliant but really really
funny stuff what the funniest movies
still to this day might be one of my
favorite comedies when he's like we're
serpentine serpentine art might each
house serpentine yeah he of course was
known for Columbo with his famous moment
Murder by Death
Murder by Death doing right Princess
Bride of course the bride that's right I
was feeling numb from the Princess Leia
story
you wish as you wish I did bring a
little clip I'm glad you brought up in
laws because that was the clip I brought
tonight to show this is if you haven't
seen the film do yourselves a favor go
out there and Netflix it or pick it up
it's it's very funny and it's so crazy
it's so harebrained it's so out there
it's it's a wonderful flick both of
these dudes they're comedic geniuses and
their performances and it holds up it's
a movie clearly shot in the seventies
but it'll hold up it really it current
it works now as Bob plays a guy is a CIA
agent who meets Alan Arkin who is a
dentist and they're brought together
because their kids are getting married
hence the name the in-laws and through a
series of wacky circumstances Arkin is
drawn into this caper that Peter Falk is
is running all anarchic gets to play
both the straight man and like the bleed
funny guy as well because these
restrictions his reactions are [ __ ]
prized this movie is fantastic you
haven't seen it go out and get it right
they end up down in South America this
tiny little Banana Republic it's rotted
by a dictator played by Richard
libertine he was also hilarious in it
who talks with his hand all the time and
at the end towards the end of the film
there in front of a firing squad and
it's the end it looks like they're gonna
be finished and Alan Arkin turns the
Peter book it says you're you're the CIA
Joe what are you gonna do to get us out
of this it feels like I know you got any
ideas this is the this is the
impassioned speech Peter Falk gives to
the dictator trying to save the life of
his friend Shelly this man's children
corn-fed Shelly Michael he's a great
dentist from New York a city in which as
you probably know general there are
thousands of spanish-speaking people who
stand who die in need of extensive
French work and this man said I'm afraid
would be a crushing blow to whatever
small hopes they might have for a
healthier set of teeth and gums
[Applause]
what a loss what a great great news [ __ ]
it away we'll miss you for your fog all
right let's move on to the HBO headlines
I'm surprised you guys are here tonight
actually I thought you'd be out somehow
commemorating the second anniversary of
Michael Jackson's passing tonight is the
night two years ago in this night he was
given you know an appropriate dose of
propofol if you're dr. Conrad Murray to
[ __ ] two years since he passed yeah
reason I bring it up is because one of
the headlines this week was that Channel
Island helicopters announced that they
are giving his fans a chance to toss a
single red rose out of a helicopter over
the neverland ranch tonight
and they'll all weekend long so if you
haven't booked your flight yet you can
go on there with a single red rose they
will fly you over Neverland Ranch and
you cans drop the rows out over his his
favorite place to live the company rep
promises you'll be closer to heaven and
to Michael in the helicopter it's only
175 dollars per person 500 bucks for
three so you still have time to book it
sounds like you could drop a rose and
sensible money out fo cash I have booked
my flight I am going to sprinkle young
boys pants underwear out the window as a
fitting tribute to Michael I will I will
douse Neverland Ranch with underwear I
[Music]
think that's how Michael would have
wanted it
Lindsay Lohan in the news this week as
she is every week this week she had to
go to court because she failed an
alcohol test they came to her house
where she is under house arrest they
tested her for alcohol they consider
that a violation of her probation they
hauled her ass into court turns out they
were wrong and she was right the judge
ruled that she was only required to
undergo controlled substance testing and
even then only from January until
February so apparently Lindsay can't
drink all she wants as long as she
doesn't drive after she drinks however
the judge did say that she had an ass
full of all the parties going on in her
house in Venice and so she put a new
order in place no more parties at
Lindsay's house only one visitor at a
time is allowed and Lizzie said that's
fine as long as that visitor could be
her drug dealer that's it
the judge said and she has she gotten in
trouble or not because it sounds like
she could do anything she wants she's
under house arrest which means she has
to stay in her house which is a lovely
condo in Venice that overlooks the beach
and only party with one person
now she I can only play with one person
at a time yeah what it is is like a real
Sophie's Choice for her who do you
choose only Who am I gonna get [ __ ] up
with today the judge said the only thing
Lindsay was guilty of was extremely poor
judgment
I bet Lindsay felt bad
glug glug glug glug glug
well that wash that away yellow person
who apparently isn't invited into her
house is Matt Lauer he flew from New
York from the Today Show to do an
interview with Lindsay and then when he
got when he got there she said no no
thanks now apparently it has to do with
this fact that she did fail the the
alcohol test and she was embarrassed and
did want to deal with that during the
interview but Matt Lauer apparently was
pissed off he came all that way and
didn't get to make her airtight with a
couple of his friends if I if I heard
this story correctly I believe she was
they were supposed to do an interview
for The Today Show 15 minutes but then
he also said hey while we're here we're
doing it for this other show one of the
news magazine shows like Dateline or
something like that and that's when she
was like no no there's supposed to be
for the Today Show because the Today
Show be a softball interview right the
other one would be more like so with a
fox problem with you yeah so she didn't
want to do the latter for some reason
and that was why she was kind of like no
no I'm not gonna do it and she made him
wait and finally that dude was like [ __ ]
it he left
could you imagine man he's just like a
Matt Lauer [ __ ] you leavin man I know Al
Roker ya know people well she's stuck in
her house he's apparently is making some
money she filmed a commercial there this
week for a company called B's it.com B's
it for those who don't know it's like a
really shitty version of eBay where you
pay up front like some sort of
membership fee they're not sponsor or
anything are they are they really
they're written there are a great
version of eBay that's what I meant to
say
[Applause]
I had no idea you people are the only
people who are ever hear that joke
it will never exist outside of this room
to be fair to be fair they haven't
started yet they're about to start for
whom for Jay and Silent Bob get jobs
okay well then just ignore all that I
like it I believe it it did we'll
probably lose them but it's worth it no
it's not no it's not
save your sponsor kill the joke but she
did the commercial and well they offered
her $25,000 which initially she turned
down so apparently she got more than
that Plus whatever she got in cash he
also got $10,000 in free stuff just to
merge in merch yeah but I think it's a
great idea for them to get her because
think of the commercial are you trapped
in your home with an ankle bracelet one
of the things that really sucks about
home arrest is you can't get out to shop
that's why I like to go to BZ calm
because there I can just buy buy buy on
the internet I never have to leave my
home so I party with one person and
together we get loaded and we just order
[ __ ] off Abby said you should too
I'm Lindsay Lohan and I'm airtight thank
you thank you so much you can use that
at the spot he says the commercial for
Visa total Emma listen to this what was
that first thing he said but another
another listen that listen to the
airtight bit that'll help you sell your
family product while we're talking about
hot chicks who are marginally talented
Megan Fox was in the news this week
apparently she was fired from the
Transformers franchise not by Michael
Bay but by executive producer Steven
Spielberg whoa turns out Spielberg did
not care for her Hitler joke when it
came to director Michael Bay she did an
interview after the second movie and she
said you know Michael likes to be like
Hitler on his set and he is he's a
nightmare to work for but when he get
him away from the set he's not in
director mode I really kind of enjoy his
personality because he's so awkward so
hopelessly awkward she added Spielberg
apparently heard the Hitler comment and
insisted
according to BAE who told this to the
Daily Mail you know the Hitler thing
Stephen said fire her right now
so apparently that's why she lost her
job because of bringing up Hitler when
it came to Michael Bay whoa Spielberg
said Michael Bay is not Hitler if
anything he's muscley me he says so it's
not as bad because muscle weenie got the
train there on guys he was the good
dictator how much it takes to piss off
Steven Spielberg well he's touchy about
the whole Nazi thing he doesn't really
dig the not Kim Kardashian say we're
going down the talent change pull no
talent Kim Kardashian who will go to any
length for a little free publicity and
now it's this week that she's tired of
people saying that her butt isn't real
and you know we're all saying it if you
go anywhere you hear people saying you
know Kim Kardashian's but I don't think
it's real yeah well the day I was
pointing at her ass going fraud that was
to your daughter to both of us so she is
finally putting this to rest she grabbed
her sister Chloe who has breast implants
and a penis
and pulled her into the doctor's office
and got x-rays of Chloe's fake boobs and
her real ass to prove that there are no
implants in her ass and then released
the photo to the public and we wouldn't
be a news organization people if we
didn't bring you that photograph here's
Kim Kardashian posing with the x-ray of
her ass proving that it's all real
Armenian meat to people now can we
finally stop talking about her ass and
get back to the deficit and the job
situation and gay marriage please thank
you tell you man gee I don't know much
about her but I do appreciate living in
a world where that's news because that
means nothing else is going on man like
nothing pressing like imagine we're in
Japan they don't have like a Kim
Kardashian x-ray a story they're like
we're trying not to die here this
radiation everywhere we're like really
in America we're still worried about
this idiot yeah they're trying to get
rid of radiation she's taking radiations
to prove that her ass is real why you
put it in your ass
you should stop there we got plenty here
come over here we're gonna wait turn
your hands for nothing
you walk down a street it's like x-ray
I'm getting emails that was that was
bored Kim Jong he'll open but Japanese a
no Japanese his mother Oh Kim Kardashian
ask most honorable I stand corrected sir
you're gonna [ __ ] use racial
stereotypes get it right get it right
ah sad news this week one of my
favorites got into trouble with the law
tone Lok total Oaks in trouble
[Music]
funky cold Medina yeah apparently tone
got in trouble when he erupted up the
daughter excuse me the mother of his
child
it's bad enough dude he just roughed up
the mother it's cool it's fine she was
an adult he just roughed her up
are you gonna lead with that story like
he beat a kid like no like no no just a
woman [ __ ] cool Liz hit it the mother
of his child apparently was roughed up
in Burbank personally I was shocked
because I was like they're black people
in Burbank I didn't know I didn't know
is what I'm saying I didn't say it's a
bad thing or a good thing I'm just
saying I didn't know take that joke
right - its racist says doing in the kim
jongseo boys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do me a favor put that in the B zip file
with I'm not sure I want that one out
there in the world either tone of course
had two huge hits in the 80s Wild Thing
and funky cold Medina he's being held on
$50,000 bond why don't you just make it
40 billion dollars because tone has
snorted away all that Wild Thing money a
long long time ago yeah don't broker
knows more music news Mariah Carey you
mean to step on that I'm sorry took a
while to get to this side of the table
she's still here people were listening
roller derby girls still here on stage
with us
she's a blocker man she's stopping
anybody from getting up here she is
jamming us if you will now we know my
why Mariah Carey had her twins it's
about time they started [ __ ] earning
a little money Mariah Carey's shopping
around the photos of her children
Moroccan and Monroe to the highest
bidder her and who's her husband Nick
what's the head mister Mariah yes mr.
and mrs. Mariah are looking to get big
big money for pictures of Moroccan in
Monroe but apparently they've been
disappointed because nobody wants to pay
big money for Moroccan America's no one
cares madam exactly that's why you're
right
so far two hundred grand apparently is
the biggest offer they've got for the
kids that that is nobody that their
disappointment 400 grand
yes they were looking for Brangelina
money they have set the bar Brad and
Angelina apparently they sold their
photos of Shiloh for $1,000,000 but they
gave it all to charity
I don't think Mariah and Nick Cannon are
giving their money away to charity they
just want it for the sake of havin it
yeah exactly man I can't like [ __ ]
give my kids picture away they're
actually thinking of charging how about
200 grand is the low that's that's
that's what they're disappointed and
that's what they're being offered right
now is them I feel like if you believe
somebody's gonna give us $200,000 in
cash
these pictures of this [ __ ] this come
that became a human I came out of my
dick in your [ __ ] this is crazy
that's the conversation they're had the
conversation oh yeah I know but that's
not the conversation I've been really
high when I was having it but that's
what it's all about it's crazy and they
couldn't name any more [ __ ] up to make
it more interesting
Moroccan that's pretty interesting I
want to see a picture of someone named
Moroccan I've never seen a Moroccan
before Roxy the Moroccan but not a
person named a Moroccan Justin Bieber's
got problems
other than the fact that everyone in
this room hates him he's got problem
apparently Justin's latest problem is
teenage girls keep stealing his
underwear I've had that problem for
years you and me both amigo that's my
story going commando can't steal this
gun yet it's attached it disappoints and
yet delights the thievery it's got a
king look look after those dudes who
might be burgling fall back so justin
has come up with unique solutions
according to absolute nail calm the
entertainment news website justin is now
burning all of his underwear after just
one wearing oh that's like some [ __ ]
like Farrow chic kind of [ __ ] man that's
it that doesn't sound real really well
let's ask him Justin are you really
burning your underwear after just one
wearing okay I don't want to see the
bacon stings Justin I don't have time to
wipe no just get some moist towelettes
or something that won't fix that problem
so wait he just doesn't want his panties
falling into the enemy's hands yes it so
he's being women it's it's weirding him
out so anyone's gonna have him burned
now after he wears them that's just
that's a little much yeah yeah I hope
he's still in the wild he sets fire he's
smooth like a Ken doll down there
nothing's gonna happen
while we're talking about clothing and
celebrities Jennifer Lopez had a
wardrobe malfunction this week she was
appearing on German television this is a
confusing story because it's a German TV
show that was filming in Spain get your
[ __ ] together Europe forgot who you are
and where you're filming
don't leave your respective countries
stay there so we know where to find you
really
they were shooting at a bullfighting
arena and she was wearing a very flowing
dress and apparently the wind was
whipping around and started to be one of
those Marilyn Monroe moments where he
was gonna whip up and so the host tried
to push her dress down and while doing
so while she was doing it to her boob
slipped out what everyone on German
television was watching live saw
Jennifer Lopez's right tit really yes
and we wouldn't be a news organization
if we didn't bring you a picture
Jennifer lópez's right kid pulling out
of her dress for those of you who have
never seen a nipple we have a close-up
there you go that's Jennifer Lopez's
right nipple everyone it's so [ __ ]
weird now care how old you are I don't
even care if it's like someone you know
you see nipple you're not supposed to
you're like that's amazing the hottest
nipples but like I've never seen a
nipple drawers like that what it looks
like like I literally want to jerk off
right oh sorry you may want to go back
to your seat in the audience now we got
a little while thank God it didn't
happen on American television because
we'd have to shut down all the networks
again like we did after Janet Jackson
the Germans were like sobs we don't care
visit nipple we don't care but start
another vote Rob we don't care
why don't you x-ray her ass and see if
it's real yeah but it's not behind
everyone's not asking questions that's
the curious out tell us about the ass
the adverse of making your talk about
the earth why we're talking about the
dresses being blown up by wind a Marilyn
Monroe's dress that she wore in the
famous movie the 7-year itch that's the
classic Marilyn Monroe scene where she
is walking with that married dude played
by actor Tom Hewlett the movie that
stands up by the way that film it's
pretty kind of sweet it's very dated
1950s but they're walking along it's
very hot summer in New York and no one
has air-conditioning because it's the
olden times and she's standing in front
of a subway grate on top of a subway
grate rather and the the train goes by
and it blows her dress up but she holds
it down but she eats a nice cool breeze
in her country Oh sweaty and hot oh this
cool breeze makes it feel much better
that's what she said that's her subtext
that's her inner monologue although
those the cut scene so that dress the
one she wore in that scene went on up
for auction this week and I'm a
collector
I collect 1960s Batman stuff right so
I'm like a collectibles and I get into
this stuff when I see what happened
tonight and I have some interest but
usually
report on it because no one else really
cares because it's a it's a it's a weird
niche world the world with the
collectables but this thing was worth
talking about this dress sold this week
for four point six million dollars make
sense to me it's iconic it's an iconic
piece of wardrobe everyone at mostly
everybody maybe not so much of a current
generation but a lot of people know that
[ __ ] dress whoever bought it man it's
kind of an investment they could put it
on display Marilyn Monroe is like even
like 3040 years after death is still a
cult a pop cultural icon right wore that
dress I don't know if you heard me
though I think it even weirder is who
owned the dress Debbie Reynolds in that
weird
how did Debbie Reynolds how did you how
did Princess Leia's mother wind up with
Marilyn Monroe's dress no man I'm not
sure that's how she got it then she may
have purchased it from an auction that
Fox had getting rid of their wardrobe I
think my version is sexier yeah let's
ask the Swedes
what do you think Swedes oh they're
[ __ ] never mind what's that it
Reynolds this actress those you don't
know she is Carrie Fisher's mom but she
was also a huge movie star in the 50s
apparently took all of her money and she
used to do a lot of touring and singing
and dancing shows and nightclubs and
stuff took all of her money and bought
[ __ ] with it like collectible stuff
costumes props all this stuff and
they're finally auctioning off all of
her stuff and it's worth obviously 4.6
million dollars just for one dress
another mountain road dress went for 1.7
million dollars the one she wore and
Gentlemen Prefer Blondes where she's
singing diamonds are a girl's best
friend right that dress judy garland's
ruby slippers from The Wizard of Oz that
she wore in the rehearsals and the early
shoots before they decided to go with a
different set of ruby slippers that
ended up in the movie follow that if you
want buckers
essentially these are shoe just shoes
these are these are ruby slippers that
never showed up in the movie The Wizard
of Oz they sold for 1.75 million dollars
that would be like at one point you were
gonna wear a different shirt and red
stain I was like give him a brown shirt
and they gave you a brown shoe right so
I took the other one and I just put it
in the drawer good Charlie Chaplin's
bowler only went for a hundred and
thirty-five thousand [ __ ] you Charlie
Chaplin signed a movie [ __ ] that's
what that is
and Elizabeth Taylor the outfit she wore
National Velvet is the movie that made
her starved she was like 12 or 13 that
went for $73,000 which shows that
everyone's glad she's dead now what that
shows at all my bad
all right Glee in the news this week
really there's still Glee fans
[Applause]
when did we start letting 12-year olds
in the audience that's what I would know
I started watching Glee I liked it
initially now I'm sort of off the Glee
band when you're done glucan yeah I'm
done Glee c'n but the producer this week
announced that his cast is going to
graduate next year they've been on the
air for three seasons they started off
as sophomores whatever when they're done
their time in high school they're gone
they're out and they're gonna bring a
whole new bunch of kids in to be in the
glee club okay which in a related story
all the kids from the league killed
themselves this week no I'm sure they'll
go on to excellent careers after the
show so the teachers get to stay they
get to stay finally he's off to be old
and show business for once in a while
Jane Lynch I guess I'm an old lesbian I
get to keep my job
oh yeah secret I'm not outing her she's
had a longtime wife and everything oh
really happy yeah interesting news this
week about Jeff Conaway
who we lost three and a half weeks later
back in Greece right also was on taxi
his friend and I put this in quotes is
talking to the press saying that Jeff
committed suicide Jeff Cohen is his name
he said that he believes he doesn't
believe it he's insisting that Jeff
Conaway committed suicide because he was
in so much pain and so miserable with
his addiction that he ordered an
undetectable suicide drug from Canada
and that's how he did the deed that's
why they never found it in the autopsy
because Canada has a secret suicide drug
I always knew they couldn't be trusted
those [ __ ] Canadians with their
undetectable suicide drug talking about
the only suicide drug that I'd ever want
from Canada there's boxes and boxes of
Timbits yes they make doughnuts there
they're donuts or call it Tim Hortons is
their doughnut area and they make these
little like munchkins Dunkin Donuts
versions of munchkins but they're called
Tim bits and I would that's how I would
go or Putin Putin which is like french
fries dumped poutine dumped with cheese
on top of it gravy
cheese curds and gravy essentially it's
like disco fries for us back east that's
their version of disco and that's a
suicide drug right there you eat that in
your heart will stop yeah
those cheese curds are thick man all
right my favorite stuff of the week is
in this next section celebrity
relationship news Daniel Craig and
Rachel vice got married this week what I
brought you some news [ __ ] how about
that usually it's like Oh dance funny
monkey dance but now I bring you some
actual news this just broke today mother
[ __ ] I am plugged the [ __ ] in Daniel
Craig and Rachel vice got married if
you're Darren Aronofsky the director who
was with Rachel vice the beautiful
stunning yes this guy said oh [ __ ] and I
agree beautiful and talented she's
really getting the whole package he was
with her for seven years and I'm sorry
nine years and then she broke up with
him and now she's married to Daniel
Craig just months after they started
dating you got to say I'm cool with that
right Daniel Craig eats these DS the guy
right yeah she just wants something
better than me that's all
yeah they got married she is 41 he is 43
apparently they got married a very small
ceremony in New York this week so
congratulations to Daniel Craig and
Rachel I want to come in under you you
know I played Captain Von Trapp inside
of music you just literally rolled over
I just wanted to come in under you
and you're so busy Hawking a performance
from 30 years ago
goddamned comic didn't even hearing a
big ass joke like that I could tell you
that I played Captain Von Trapp when I
was 14 I apologize fix that in post a
couple it's not doing as well as Rachel
vice and Daniel Craig are Camille and
Kelsey Grammer you know they split up
they divorced she was I was on the NHL
Awards this right yeah he was there too
I had no idea why the shoes on the Real
Housewives or whatever yeah she they
presented an award so the whole time
there's somebody there who was like that
looks like Frazier's mother and it was
this lady she's upset with Kelsey
Grammer because apparently there was an
email that went out this week from
kelsey Grammer's account that said
Camille smells like beef jerky all of
her friends and business so she has got
the email but Kelsey is claiming that it
wasn't from him he says other people had
access to his password and he refuses to
apologize again dude I'm glad we live in
a world where this is a [ __ ] news
story where it's just like it's not like
even Caldera [ __ ] he/she smells like
a [ __ ] queef or something like that
he's like she smells like beef jerky
it's like the four year olds [ __ ]
insult that's why I think it did come
from him because it sounds so much like
a Frazier line do it do your Frasier fir
god sakes Niles the woman smells like
beef jerky i buy it right well you would
say yeah but I have to be fair if you
put for God's sakes Niles in front of
anything got fakes nice one smells like
a queef yeah works in anything you say
it doesn't work George Clooney and
Elisabetta Canalis broke up this week
that's the builing president is very
happy for that why does that make you
happy it's like I had my chance at
George well I didn't yeah George isn't
oh you just think he should be freezer
to get [ __ ] anyone he want
what a team player you are it's amazing
I wish I had that kind of support in my
life he's like break up with your wife
so you could [ __ ] all the women you want
I can't you do it for me yeah the gray
fox as they call him as a free man
ladies so get in line apparently they
have released a statement this week
saying it's very difficult it's very
personal and they hope that everyone
will respect their privacy nope cannot
make that guarantee she's hot though
that was a bit I don't know who that is
she is a an Italian I guess he's been
with her for a while yeah yeah she
mentioned marriage you're right she did
bring up the M word is that what she
said you know oh because it was in all
the press she said I I'm pro marriage
I'd like to be married someday and
George read that and said oh I forgot to
mention I'm George [ __ ] Clooney I
forgot to [ __ ] this girl over here
gotta go Hugh Hefner has already found a
rebound girl after his marriage broke up
last week we're you guys worried that
Hef wouldn't have another girlfriend
immediately after the other girl dumped
him Oh nurse are they happy are you guys
happy that he didn't get married or that
he found someone new this guy ed [ __ ]
McMahon he's very opinionated though Hef
finally is dating a woman who is older
which I think we're all happy for his
new girlfriend
Anna Bergland Bergland what
Anna Berlin is 24 days older than his
fiancee crystal Harris
she's also 25 but she's just a little
bit older so she's more of an older
woman she's mature it's about time he's
dating somebody closer to his age here's
a photo of Hef and his new girlfriend
well they seem like a happy couple
Hef tweeted this week after all is said
and done maybe staying single is
probably the best I think I just missed
a bullet your prostates gonna kill you
before a bullet does so prostate kill
you faster than a bullet old man
meanwhile Hef did the classy thing and
he let gold-digging [ __ ] I'm sorry
crystal Harris
[Music]
[Applause]
keep her three carat diamond engagement
ring let her keep the ring 90 K is what
that ring is worth you know how we know
that's what it's worth
because she tried to sell it this week
in La Jolla real she went to I mean I
guess that's what you do right gentleman
said he should have let the Jared get a
better deal at Jared's you're right
why can't Jared's be a sponsor that was
a good one I don't know there's a jump
on now wait can we redo it and said they
she should have gave her a man grade
he should have gone on B's in comm ah
well then she was in a la jolla jewelry
store down by San Diego this week and
she took off the ring and gave it to the
dude said can I get appraisal in this I
want to know how much it's worth and so
the guy said I need to know what the
documentation is so the [ __ ] has the
balls to call the Playboy Mansion and
say I need the details about this ring
because I'm looking to sell it and the
person on the other end said we'll fax
it to you but we can't get it to you
right away and apparently she stormed
out of the the store very upset that you
couldn't sell the ring on the spot
apparently the guy who was waiting on
this is according to witnesses so take
it or leave it for what it's worth said
sorry to hear about the the marriage
going south and she reportedly said are
you kidding it was all for publicity
yeah but come on hold on
do you really think that she's gonna
reveal our innermost secrets to the
[ __ ] guy she's trying to sell a ring
to like that sounds made-up
a real real smart girl like Crystal
Harris you're right you got a point I'm
sorry I know what I was saying and while
we're talking about may-december
romances my favorite story of the week
I'm so giddy familiar with an a grenade
Doug hutchinson Doug Hutchinson is 51
years old he played Percy the guard in
The Green Mile
he was also unlost he played was the
name of that character and lost he was
the head of the Dharma Initiative on
lost but they went back in time Horace
Horace Goodspeed was his name dude is 51
years old this week he married I [ __ ]
you not a 16 year old girl her name is
Courtney Alexis Stodden they got married
in Las Vegas this week he is 51 maybe
didn't hear me she is 16 years old here
is a photo of the lovely couple alright
there's sixteen and then there's sixteen
okay she didn't look 16 then no she
doesn't know he said in their statement
we're aware that our vast age difference
is extremely controversial but we want
but we're very much in love and we want
the message out there that true love can
be ageless
as can viagra now here's the thing they
had to get permission to get married
via Nevada law from one of her parents
and her mother signed off and said my
sixteen-year-old can get married to this
51 year old man she also made a
statement we are totally supportive of
this marriage Kourtney's mom said Doug
is a wonderful man and we love him she
also added Courtney was a virgin when
she married Doug she is a good Christian
girl she is a beautiful girl
she has real breasts real lips she's not
plastic mom said it's a mother that's
her mother making that statement we get
another picture of Courtney up there
just so we can look for ourselves
whether she's plastic or not oh you're
right you're right she is a good
Christian girl I was like my mother out
there in the world going Tiger has a big
dick not plastic at all's and he's just
big-boned
apparently Courtney is trying to launch
a music career imagine that indeed madam
aren't they all well she could sing
about how much she loves her grandfather
[Music]
and our boy Hutchinson has a management
company and he's managing her career
that's how they got together now she's
got a new single out people
and I wouldn't be doing you justice and
I didn't bring me a little taste of her
video the song is called don't put it on
me wait wait wait I know it's called
don't put it on me don't put it in now
now yeah I know problem with that oh
don't put it on me it's called um this
is gonna run a little bit longer than
our average clip here on Hollywood
babble-on because there's a bit of
you've got to be [ __ ] kidding me to
this clip and I want you to get over
that so you can really enjoy the song so
here's a little bit of an elongated
taste of the new video for don't put it
on me
[Music]
it's not my [ __ ] you can't control
[Music]
there you go 16 years old I don't know
at you I thought she was gonna [ __ ] the
dog on the bunny hi figured that was the
next step that looks like amateur porn I
just don't understand like why people
gave Rebecca Black so [ __ ] like that
video is one shot you're in a [ __ ]
pink dog that's just like what's
happening I'm a dog long in the water
yeah I apologize to Rebecca black I
really do
she clearly uh she clearly clearly
clearly looks like a virgin she's not a
plastic girl the Christian very
Christian all right a couple cheese from
run that time aren't we all right I'm
gonna turn
[Music]
I want to talk about the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences this is
the people the people give out the
Oscars every year they've just announced
they've invited 178 new people to join
their ranks which i think is a good idea
you want new blood in there it's very
impressive they invite people from all
different walks of life in the showbiz
in the movie industry
remember 97 they invited you're a member
of the boat so you get to vote on all
the stuff right and that yeah everything
but my branches directors branch oddly
enough you don't get to vote for
directors my branch is directors branch
oddly enough so yeah I definitely but
you get to vote for the other stuff too
a best picture ever something yeah yeah
they invited a bunch of people this is
what their statement said there these
are people who have distinguished
themselves by their contributions to the
theatrical motion pictures these
individuals are among the best
filmmakers working in the industry today
they released the list of people who
have been asked to join and these are
the new members and I wanted to bring up
a couple names in the actors category
specifically because just keep in mind
when you're watching the Oscars and
saying this is [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
why cuz these are the people they
invited okay there are some names in
here you can absolutely see like vincent
cassell who i think is a great great
actor he was in Black Swan he played the
the choreographer the guy read the whole
thing
great guys dude French actor French
actor has done a ton of stuff real high
quality stuff however Russell Brand is a
new member of the Academy Russell Brand
the man who gave you not only get him to
the Greek but Arthur is a member of the
Academy yeah I know he's [ __ ] Katy
Perry you know what then put him in the
hot [ __ ] Academy but don't put him in
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences don't you have to make a movie
that's watchable before you become a
member of the Academy I mean I'm a again
I got adopted in 97 and I had made
Mallrats all right
there are a lot of people that say that
I don't belong but I don't you didn't
like get him to the Greek I was fine but
I mean Jennifer Garner Jennifer Garner's
now in the Academy again and Arthur and
Arthur alumni I know she was in Juneau
but really just barely ghost town come
on people you should be upset about this
Beyonce no I think you've got a cover
no it wasn't she in Dreamgirls of the
names you've listed so far at least she
wasn't she nominated or yeah she was
nominated she's an actor oh we need foxy
Cleopatra in the [ __ ] Academy that's
what they thought to themselves teo
leone is in the Academy now David
accompanies wife that's how she's known
by the way the company's also in this
year maybe they did a package deal maybe
it's like like a cruise or somebody
Dubai to you get an extra stateroom oh
they just he's just in this year yeah
David company's in Beyonce Knowles
real quick Russell Brand Jerry Butler
all right Butler can understand yes
Jennifer Aniston so they should pull him
right out of the [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
Jennifer Aniston the movie it was called
yeah Bradley Cooper movie star you know
I can see because he's a movie star John
Corbett lamb Corbett's been around
forever I can see those a guy who's done
a ton of good performances and a ton of
different kinds of films I can see why
they would induct a guy like they just
want some hot [ __ ] in the Academy that's
why they are Peter Dinklage he's in yeah
that's cool station agent my [ __ ]
friend Brad will tell you that's a cool
thing that's one for the [ __ ] spread
no he's a [ __ ] ask him Brad what are
you thank you sir
he's taking the work back Mila Kunis
honestly dude she deserves it for
forgetting sarah marshall she was so
[ __ ] yeah and that was just showered
with Oscars Jennifer Lawrence she was
nominated so she got Anthony Mackie he
was in Hurt Locker yeah it's all over
the place a little bit crazy yeah Rooney
Mara that's the chick who's in the new
was Dragon Tattoo dragon did you see
that poster yeah weird the bubonic I
know it's like a Jennifer Lopez boobs
you know
flat out like look at my nipple like
Ellen Page she's known for someone who
does really good work with Juno and
inception everything she's like an
oppression Amin
right so you can see why she would be
included but Dominic Monaghan he was
[ __ ] Charlie and lost that's the only
I know
oh he's yeah when he was in Lord of the
Rings and that was nominated
walked around looking for a place to
throw the [ __ ] ring we know that in
San Oscars are [ __ ] that's what I've
decided as opposed to the real award
which is the star in the Hollywood Walk
of Fame let's talk about I am very happy
for you I saw this story earlier this
week and I was like wow this is this is
it I hope you folks have heard or not
but after after years and years
literally you guys you may or may not
know but I have been personally the guy
behind the campaign to get this guy a
song we got the news this week but Adam
West will finally be enshrined on
Hollywood Boulevard I got an email this
week from Adam West that said Ralph
thank you you are the guy who poured the
cement for my star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame okay like Gretzky say to you you
smooth the ice with the samboni for my
Stanley company I would say you were
more the Commissioner Gordon man you
called and he came that you summon the
bat form so that is Fanta how old is
this man he is 82 years old he should
have had this star [ __ ] 30 years ago
but God bless him he's getting it now
and these days battle that that honor
usually is reserved for sadly studios
who were trying to push a movie project
or something's coming out on DVD and
they make it a pickle always very timed
with somebody doing something else so to
get a grassroots campaign off the ground
and get somebody an award just based on
a body of work is very difficult I've
tried for years his daughter Nina who's
a friend of mine now because we kind of
combined our efforts she tried for years
so it took seven or eight years before
they finally did it but this week we
found out so I was just happy to uh I am
not I did not get married in the
batmobile as you did Ralph but I spent
many many many long hours as a child
watching every episode of Batman a
little black-and-white TV with rabbit
ears in my kitchen because my father was
watching bowling for dollars in the
other room but you had to see that in
color yeah but it's he is a big big part
of our childhoods it's nice you know
like I do I give a [ __ ] about a star no
but it means something for this guy cuz
he is a [ __ ] Hollywood legend and he
does belong on that walk somewhere and
now he that but with Family Guy he's the
mayor of Quahog of course some family
guy he has sort of book ended his career
with two big you know culture phenomenon
so we're happy for him and I'll be do we
know when we don't know when it's gonna
happen yet but I decided that you know
it's like it's like 30 grand to put one
of these stars in the ground really oh
those 14 back in the day so I don't want
him to have to pay for any of it so
we're gonna do some fundraising events
and I decided that this theater has been
so kind to us that I want to do like a
James Lipton behind the Actors Studio
kind of evening with Adam West beautiful
where Adam and I will fit up on this
stage and we're gonna sell tickets and
we're gonna go over his whole career I
mean the guy was working from the you
know the 50s all the way up through now
he's got a ton of great stories so we're
gonna do an evening without him West
here at this theater in the next couple
months or so and then all the proceeds
will go to help
[Applause]
so Burt Ward will not be invited because
we don't have enough food in the kitchen
[Laughter]
you see Burt would know yeah well you
know some horny Jenny Craig Batman
somewhere Burt warders going have you
seen Kevin Smith you've dropped the
tongues go he's really found it alright
uh look at that blue light means we're
almost out of time like it's so much
good stuff well we got to get the amy
winehouse at least right do you have
clips of this amy winehouse drunk off
her ass in belgrade serbia this is
[ __ ] sad this was the kickoff of her
European tour now keep in mind she went
into rehab - I see what they used to
make fun of me whenever I jumped in so
I'm like I'm not going no no no but
that's cuz they want to do it fine she
went into rehab so she could get sober
enough to perform this 12 City European
tour it's pretty ironic 12 steps if you
were well step well if you fall off the
first step this was her opener in
Belgrade Serbia she performed for 90
minutes and by performed I mean stumbled
and slurred for 90 minutes let's just
say she was there for 90 minutes there's
a ton of great video on youtube if you
want to see any of it help yourself
everybody shooting the [ __ ] did you
bring anything I brought you everybody
there's like I watched one I was like oh
man I wish there was a closer angle
there was
and then when I was done watching that
one another angle enough like apparently
everybody was [ __ ] shoot yeah this
thing was covered better than Academy
Award red carpet everyone added a new
angle and a new version I brought you a
little taste of a song she was singing
by singing I mean
moaning stumbling through the song is
called addicted coincidentally enough
here is Amy Winehouse just just magic
[Music]
[Music]
now I know what it must be like for you
to work with me every week you look like
I'm gonna go to the room after the show
you're just like hugging your arm
playing with my fake tits playing with
my one clip I saw her she was singing
this other song and she's so [ __ ] up
she starts adjusting her hair her wig
she's got like a massive wig and she
looks like she's gonna pull it right the
four things you gotta pull it off and
then you're just like oh here come the
panties yeah but yeah she's clearly who
the [ __ ] pushes her out on stage and
goes go management yeah out of a
management like if any smart manager
goes you can't if we put it on stage
gonna hurt us in the future you know
what I'm saying like let's take the hit
tonight and figure out maybe she took
too many hits the needle yeah I don't
know I just wouldn't push her out there
cuz that's just killing the Amy
Winehouse business in the future cuz
well I guess you got her there yeah
there's 20,000 people out there now
here's the thing the tickets were like I
know 75 pounds or die would that
translate 45 euros whatever it was but
the average monthly income for a Serbian
is 200 or something so these were
expensive expenses huge if twenty
thousand people have paid that to see
this woman they're there she's there
what do you do do you cancel yeah should
have canceled the rest of the tour she
is [ __ ] 90 minutes alert
[Music]
most of you here the entire audience
singing the song trying to will her
somehow to give her performance
everyone's watching a girl living better
off oh we're so late but I get to so
much stuff let me just burn through some
stuff real quick Julia Ormond apparently
gonna play Lara from Krypton for
Superman Ramez naam yeah
geek news real quick James let's hit
that and we'll get through quick some
quick geek news and then we'll jump
right in
[Music]
Julie Orman gonna play Laura to Russell
Crowe's jor-el from the planet Krypton
you just said that I know I'm just
repeating it after the jingle so [ __ ]
up every week here but you've never seen
me that bad
and oh you're high that you should
applaud my alcoholism your app saying
you're a functioning alcoholic this
emphasis on the function right
rollergirl
[Applause]
christopher meloni also added to the
Superman cast this command to Chris
Meloni apparently is going to play a
general in the film that's all they're
telling us we don't know what general is
that Zod because because that's like a
short Michael Schell Michael Shannon's
got that gig so he's due they're gonna
play another Kryptonian or he's going to
play a Earth's general Earth general who
was fighting against the Kryptonians on
our side the Superman so so is that the
plot do we know that the plot is
apparently Zod is the main villain so
far as far as we know but what do you
make a great Luthor Christopher Meloni
you just shaved that [ __ ] head and
just are they uploading a lutheran this
we don't know their keep their bits very
close to the bestest I mean I guess it's
tough to do Superman without Luthor
Luthor but Jesus every Batman without
Joker the first movie so maybe that's
true let me just get through some stuff
here sorry oh I got dude this story
because it's just sweet sweet sweet it
happened a little while ago but we can't
go without mentioning it and the only
reason I want to do is because it was
sent to me this week I didn't know about
it but here's the clip of the Ewok made
the Ewok picture up there James you
could show us this news story hit the
news paper
Ewok on indecency charge it reads
Nicholas Reed who played an Ewok and
Return of the Jedi was arrested for
showing his penis to a 17 year old on a
train this week it gets funnier
Nicholas Reed was playing one of the
Seven Dwarfs in a snow-white
pantomime which is like a play they do
in England right he had a bottle of gin
a
according to friends he got on the train
on the way home from the show
Brad's dissidence holding to you at all
I'm sorry I forgot we have a I have a
[ __ ] friend in the crowd tonight I
don't want to be too rude he got on the
on the train in his dwarf costume took
off his dwarf hat what it is laughs
pulled out his [ __ ] and then a 17 year
old was sitting across from over the
Train he started flashing his [ __ ] by
lifting up the dwarf hat periodically
and giving her the eyes look down in
here look down here showing off his
dwarf copy that's your guy totally
ripped you off
I believe that move is called the hi-ho
thank you and good night Nicholas who
also played one of the Gringotts goblins
in the Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone played an Ewok
warrior in Return of the Jedi how old is
this guy he is 40 all right so they made
I'm 40 okay would you like to show us
your [ __ ] yes it just means they made
return the Jedi like 1982 so he was what
12 when he was in Return of the Jedi
maybe they had bernau rows apart he
placed his hat on his crotch said the
young lady who was the victim of the
crime I didn't know whether to believe
it or not she said he tilted the hat
towards me lifted it so I could see the
lewd behavior continued for 30 to 40
minutes she added he tried to catch my
attention tilting up his hat looking at
his crotch and then looking at me a few
times she told the cops who showed up
and when they took him into court they
asked him why didn't you just hang your
hat up on the coat rack sir
he answered I [ __ ] you not in court
because I couldn't reach
he has been found guilty has not been
charged yet but apparently there was
another previous incident in 2004 he was
also performing in a snow white play in
England where he climbed into bed with
the stage manager and his girlfriend had
assaulted the woman before she knew that
he was there he is one pervy little Ewok
a dude [ __ ] just sitting on the train
just putting a hat over at that time a
believable maybe he was just trying to
hide this punch of cold ifile and that
was good
straight from Dublin alright as we end
every show we're also doing this week
with a segment that's got started by
John McGuire in Glasgow Scotland he
started a tumblr called Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] tumblr calm Kevin's of course
obsessed with the size of Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] so every week we take a look at
some of the more interesting facts about
Liam's [ __ ] the segment we like to call
how big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
we can't help but wonder how big the
chickadee home is literally it was a
quiet moment she goes how big is Liam
Neeson's GOG what were the folks who
have not been initiated the reason
Kevin's obsessed is because Janice
Dickinson the supermodel claimed she
slept with Liam Neeson to be fair I've
been fascinated by his dick long before
she said I was one of the first things
ever confirmed it for you yes she came
out in public and said he was hung like
a [ __ ] haveon bottle the large size
yeah the big one not even the little one
but when I first got into the business
that was one of the first thing somebody
told me I was like hey man who's got the
biggest dick of the business just joking
around without missing a beat they were
like Oh Liam Neeson yeah I said kid that
is like [ __ ] huge come down to his
Neos at Gennady or Shitler logo yeah
well now now it's been confirmed and
here exactly how big Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's
actually in all six Star Wars films also
three Star Trek sequels to Bond films
and was the original Darren on B which I
did not know that Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big his brand of commed condoms are
made by a company called lamb Holocaust
what no one actually killed the Lambs
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he won
season 12 of the Biggest Loser just by
weighing in with an erection and then
again five minutes later without one
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it
understands everything that happened on
lost Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when
it looks up it can't see Liam Neeson
over its gut Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that he once went to the doctor
because of an uncontrollable swelling
the doctor found a wild boar inside
still being digested
sugar suspect chill see because it's
even its own Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big he has to squint to make out who's
blowing him I gotta say who's your
delivery that's no bad joke that was
great
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that when
he does helicopter dick he actually
flies damn I got a couple more pages
Mike we should assume that whatever the
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big then
instead of sexting he just lies on his
back and tells the chick to look out the
window Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
Stephen King has nightmares about it
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he took a
picture of it last Christmas and it's
still printing Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that he has to apply lube with a
paint roller Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that before you start to ride it a
conductor comes to collect your ticket
and then gives you the option to upgrade
to a sleeper compartment and a meal Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he put the dog
in the ramma lamma ding-dong Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it's why a naked
Janice Dickinson now looks like an
inflated hot dog casing twisted into a
balloon animal of a ferret Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it could literally be
knock-knock-knocking on heaven's door
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big safe sex
means a hula hoop in a circus tent Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Gretzky refers
to it as the great one
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big and eat the
dingo that ate my baby
[Applause]
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he doesn't
give ladies pearl necklaces he gives
them cable knit sweaters
[Applause]
that might be my favorite one of the
best Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
after he comes all men fall asleep Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
if it becomes erect at high noon it can
only be viewed through poking a hole in
a shoebox appearing at Chateau Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when he gets a
hooker he has to pay her via
international bank transfer because
she's in another country Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it has become
self-conscious and now hangs out with
things larger than itself to feel better
TMZ reports Liam's [ __ ] has been seen
hanging out with Ralph's garments
eyebrows on a regular basis how dare you
sir Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
irresistible forces and a movable object
step the [ __ ] aside when it comes along
and finally Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
he doesn't catch the clap he catches the
standing ovation
go out on a better note than that man
that's it for Hollywood battle on then
this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph
Garman
[Applause]
[Music]